there's this idea that in portraiture
it's the photographer's job to set the
subject at ease i
i i don't believe that
robert penn warren was writing about
dying and death
and i just asked him to take his shirt
off but it was more like
i wanted to see his skeleton he didn't
have any
guard or shield
one of my favorite photographs agnes
martin sitting in her painting studio
she said to me i sit here and i wait to
be inspired
i love that and so i said would you just
sit there
isn't that what we all do we wait to be
inspired
[Music]
all the work that i've ever done the
ideas emanate from that person
stand over here present yourself we're
so complicated
as human beings there's so many parts to
us that's where the ideas come from
even in the most set up situation i
believe there's something real going on
i'm so not a technical photographer what
camera are you using
if that's what you're thinking about
you're not taking pictures
oh my god alice it's so beautiful when
you first start off
stay with one lens and see what it does
you may want to open up have more
latitude so when you go back you can
actually bring it back down and go dark
[Music]
i'm constantly trying to emulate natural
light
where's the light coming from she should
fall into that tree
[Music]
i should love that
photograph the people close to you your
family your friends
that's how i learned when you photograph
people
it's about history it's about looking at
our time and our culture and our society
through portraits
[Music]
you never stop seeing you're seeing all
the time don't be afraid to be
obsessed take the camera go out in the
world
find a way to tell a story that means
something
to you i'm annie leibovitz
and this is my master class
you